and and i'm also learning right now that
matt walsh was just suspended on twitter
whoa really uh
over tweets uh relating to gender so
mike cernovich is tweeting about this uh
right now so so again his voice gets
taken out here and again i disagree with
matt on some issues i agree with him on
some issues but but you know again he's
coming from a different perspective why
is he being targeted why is cnn still
the preferred platform for big tech
social media that gets to spew their
lives to the general public that's crazy
do we have the story yet
i'm trying to pull it up twitter's
annoying i was looking up the companies
at alphabet google's parent company owns
the other day and they have a lot more
companies than they did three years ago
they have like 12 now they've got
they're doing articles
wrote a story about this just a heads up
yeah the daily wire breaking matt was
suspended from twitter over
uh you know tweet about a comment that
we should even be careful because we're
living in 1984 we came well we worked
we'll we'll just focus on uh we got the
story from the daily wire as luke
mentioned matt walsh suspended from
twitter over transgender tweets here's
what twitter has censored i don't know
if we can actually show on youtube with
twitter even central exactly isn't that
type of crazy world we're living in
but don't give i'll put it this way
don't give them the benefit of the doubt
on anything no
if they're gonna censor it assume it's
it's it's correct that's it i didn't i
have not read i have not yet read what
matt walsh said
it's right
yeah if they censored it don't care i'm
sick of these games they play that
twitter is very uh
all of these platforms are very
obviously in the bag in one direction
i don't know man look they're doing
they're using legality as an excuse when
ethically it's i don't think it's
ethical it's only policy legally evil we
gotta understand we're heading towards a
very important political time this is
only going to wrap it up this is only
going to get crazier more and more
people are going to get hit and they're
slowly and surely implementing a society
where you get in trouble for wrong
thinking dude you can mute matt walsh if
you don't want to listen to it you don't
need to ban his account exactly yep if
you don't want to watch someone you
don't have to that's your choice his
tweet refers to transgender uh
trans women as men that's that's the
gist of his tweet that's that's what it
was this is what you got into it with
jack dorsey about right the fact that
um the overwhelming majority of this
country does not agree with the leftist
view on gender uh gender critical
ideology yet twitter is enforcing a
fringe gender criticism calling like a
trans woman a man in his tweet or was he
just saying trans women are no he said
the uh uh the the individual who won
jeopardy a four-star admiral he said
they were all men
and that's a bannable defense
now i suppose it's like stepping in the
fire and being like i can we can all
step in fire watch i've tweeted i've
tweeted a bunch of things people said
i'm gonna get banned for and i just
don't care but i said i tweeted once um
males are better at women's sports than
females
and i got like thousands of retweets and
i'm like i don't is that am i what's
wrong with that statement right
and so
i i think there's ways
to to like you know you can point this
out
the rules make no sense is basically i'm
trying to get to i don't know i don't i
don't even understand it anymore and
i'll say this too as it pertains to
youtube and the covet rules i don't even
know
i have no idea what the
because like they have all these rules
about what you can and can't say about
the vaccines and all that stuff but but
kovit has has we've we've got so many
different variants of covet yeah i'm
like
does this rule pertain to delta omicron
lambda which one yeah which one does or
it doesn't because if if they said
initially if you claimed vaccines wayne
and efficacy you'd get banned but now
it's like the whole narrative for the
booster so i'm like is that rule still
there i don't know it the whole point is
not to know or understand the rules the
point is just to make sure that as soon
as a new rule is in place you follow it
yes lock step no questions asked yeah
compliance no matter what and the rules
no matter how insane it is it doesn't
matter if you understand
vague on purpose yeah so then the new
ceo can come in and reinterpret it and
then all that type of people so that
they can ban what they want whenever
they want
and it's like that that old saying like
you know you know when you see it you
can't define it but you know what you
see yes obscenity yeah yeah they they
don't want you to know exactly what the
rules are but they want you to know when
you're offending the regime
it is such a power play for them to be
like well we're not really going to tell
you exactly what you can or can't say
we're just going to pull the rug out
from you under you if today we decided
this is the wrong thing to say dude it's
so dirty you can easily ban an account
and never have to think of them again as
an admin but it's so easy to contact
them and let them know why it just takes
an extra step but it's so easy to not do
it like to be lazy and just to be like
yeah
they're just uh words on a screen
they're not a real person i don't have
to think about it i'll just destroy
their livelihood how much you want to
bet more people are going to sign up for
getter you know they got over a million
yeah the amount of people signing up for
getter hit like a million yeah post
reported but there's a reason i also was
critical of getter and they're kind of
vague generalized terms of services
because they're very similar terms of
services to a lot of these big tech
outlets that of course use and abuse
them and if you're
leaving a lot of leeway and saying just
trust us i'm sorry people have been
through enough already we need more uh
reassurances we need more transparency
we need more accountability and we need
a process where people actually
understand what's going on what are the
rules and and they keep them vague in
order to of course have that draconian
power over you because you never know
what you could say cnn gets to say
whatever they want they get to eat human
brains they get to show conflict they
get to show gore they get to exploit it
they get to show people dying every
single day
independent media gets to play by a
completely different set of rules that's
not even told to them and they get hit
and punished all the time which is
ridiculous reza oslon ate human brains
he ate human brains on tv looks like
marjorie taylor green's back on twitter
did you guys see that what
14 hours ago
that's not true this is from yahoo news
i see her rep mtg account so tweeting
again interesting yahoo says she's back
yeah hey
rep empty it might be just one of her
two accounts this is maybe her no she's
got her her her um official account has
always been up but her first didn't get
that i thought they're both banned okay
so now she's tweeting personally from
her official account i think just i mean
what else well i don't know how you
define what's perfect i don't know
exactly
yeah they're like she's back and she's
tweeting again
well but she has that because they're
all the whole all-along rep mtg
yeah i was just checking her man get her
page she's up like 20 000 followers from
yeah i'm not i'm up like 150 000
followers so
the getter thing's weird because they
just copy your uh they like cloned
twitter i guess yeah it's weird so you
have followers but there's like no one
using those accounts for the most part i
don't even know if there are actual
accounts but they just like copy your
number
but when i jumped over to get her my
number went up like 150 000 people so
actually there's a lot of engagement
it's crazy and now they gained another
million users they're just creating uh
parallel uh cultures more and more and
more that's gonna be so good more people
are gonna spin up new social networks
they can federate and just become part
of this this growing organism good and
bad i guess um the issue is
if we divide
and completely disassociate from each
other then we just become like warring
factions yeah we gotta unite
there needs to be some overarching
agreement in culture and it used to be
like you know the american constitution
or even like an rss search algorithm
where you can at least see what people
are posting on different websites
constitution will be more of a computer
code like we're going to rewrite some
sort of rules it'll be a computer rule
i think
or just allow people to have personal
responsibility and understand that they
have discernment and treat them like
adults i'm a grown ass man i don't need
big tech overlords telling me what i can
and cannot listen to that idea it's so
patronized it's such an establishment
elitist belief that hey you're too
stupid for your own good we need to tell
you what to believe in that's crazy the
fact that we're here at this point where
people are deciding what you can and
cannot discern for yourself is wild it's
ridiculous and it's disrespectful to
human intelligence and it's stopping
human progress because when you when you
limit ideas when you limit debate when
you limit conversations you stop human
beings from growing and being better and
i think this is why it's done
deliberately this is done to dumb us
down to enslave us to put us in fear to
have us controlled because every step of
the way that we're seeing this
implemented it's creating a situation
where you're afraid to even express
ideas over losing your livelihood and if
we're doing this and we're the ones who
are actually talking to the individuals
out there imagine what they're going
through and their limited perspectives
that are closely slowly slowly and
surely closing in to a limited
perspective that of course the global
elites want you to have that that's
exactly what's happening here when you
say they they're getting their
perspective squishy humanity by and
large on big tech social media on the
information highways the the the ideas
that they're allowed to express the cars
that are able to be on that highway are
limited and regulated more and more and
more where it's coming
where you know uniqueness is becoming
rarer yeah the the covid one
particularly for me is really
interesting because it's first time i've
ever lived through what people have
considered a pandemic and i i would love
to talk about it all the things like
what's right what's wrong people saying
the wrong thing but in it like a place
where i don't want people to believe it
when they see it like that's up to you
don't believe this stuff and face value
any of it that's but listen to it
definitely listen to it
i i need that it makes me i want to
listen to the kooky ideas i want to
listen to the crazy ideas i want to
listen to people's perspectives that are
not mine i want to listen to ideas that
broaden my perspective and my mind i
want to have an open mind i don't want
to be force-fed ideas spoon-fed things
that i have to believe in to fit into
society that's not the way i want to
live my life and my experience
controlled and regulated by some yuppie
with flip-flops drinking his starbucks
controlling what could go into my
perception in reality are you kidding me
i want to slap that starbucks thing out
of his hand immediately shake him and be
like let humanity be free release us
from your conquest because when you
truly do release people when you truly
allow them to be free and to make their
own mistakes and to be responsible for
themselves only then do we have some
actual human progression and when
governments have been limited when
governments step out of the way that's
truly when we had the best inventions
the best progress and the best thing
that has happened to humanity throughout
recorded human history and these people
are standing in the way not just of
information but from human progress and
growth these people are enemies of free
humanity and they will do anything in
their way to subjugate you and to
conquest your existence and your true
potential i'm sick of it i'm not going
along with it and we're doing everything
we can to fight it but this notion of
open discourse cuts exactly against the
far left's idea of pre-censorship
because you know censorship is just like
take down a tweet this tweet has been
removed kind of thing but going back to
herbert marcuse's who was the architect
of the far left in many regards he
advocated for pre-censorship the people
that have ideas that are
opposed to left-wing ideology
they cannot express those ideas because
those ideas can be poisonous so that
person cannot they have to be
pre-censored so those those ideas can't
exist and people can't even hear them
because if they hear them it could be
dangerous to the to the movement
so i mean
and that's to their narratives to their
profit motives to their entire story to
their entire existence you could break
all of that with the truth thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time